[MUSIC PLAYING]
NANCY: I'm really, really
pleased to be welcoming
Professor Benjamin Bergen here
as part of Talks at Google.
So without further ado, I'm
happy to hand it over to Ben.
So.
BENJAMIN BERGEN:
Thank you, Nancy.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BENJAMIN BERGEN: So
I'm really thrilled
to be back in the homeland and
to talk to you about the topic
of my latest book.
Now, as Nancy said, there
will be strong language.
Empirically strong language.
There will be objectively the
worst words of the language
on the next slide.
So this is a great
time-- if you feel
like you might be uncomfortable
with that sort of thing--
to conveniently need to slip
out and go get some coffee.
OK, so human language
serves a variety
of communicative functions.
The function that we
usually think about
is conveying information
through time and space--
facts, descriptions of things.
And that's certainly a
thing that language does.
But it does something
else, as well.
And that's to convey emotion.
In the hot cognition
of immediate feelings,
we need some way to
communicate with conspecifics
that we're angry right now.
We're frustrated or frightened.
And this is where
profanity thrives.
So what I've tried
to do in this book
is to take an empirical,
cognitive science-based
approach to what profanity
is, how it works,
how it comes to be that
way, how it changes over
time, and importantly,
what it reveals
about our brains, our
social lives, and ourselves.
So what I wanted to do
today was to give you
a brief tour of
some of the things
that we learn about profanity
and about ourselves,
our brains, by taking
this leap of faith.
And to begin with, I
want to start empirically
by asking what
precisely profanity
is, where it comes from.
What words do we
mean by profanity?
Why are those words profane?
And if you were to ask
regulatory agencies
like the FCC, for example,
they wouldn't give you a list.
Because they haven't
done the legwork.
They don't actually
know empirically
what people think is
offensive language.
But fortunately, we
do have some evidence
from large-scale
psycholinguistics studies
that tell us broadly
what the types of words
are that people find profane.
And more specifically,
exactly which
ones a particular
group of people
find offensive at a
particular time and place.
So let's start locally.
Let's start in California with
people in their, say, 20s.
What are the worst words of
American English according
to these people?
So here's a study from
about 10 years ago at UCLA
that asked undergrads, who
would now be in their mid-20s,
how would you rate
a list of words
in terms of their offensiveness,
one word at a time?
And here are,
without further ado,
the words that are
worst in English
according to these respondents
from worst to least bad.
So some things to note,
for contemporary speakers
of American English,
including especially younger
ones, the worst
words in the language
are predominantly not the
words that George Carlin
would have told you 50
years ago are the ones you
can't say on television.
They're a new class of
words-- slurs, in fact.
Words that derogate by insulting
a particular social group
because of their
ethnicity or religion,
sex, sexual
orientation, and so on.
And in fact, you find
that a four-letter word
that starts with f is
actually 13th on the list.
We can go down the list
if you want and find
a whole bunch more offensive
words until we get down
to a famous four-letter word
that starts with S-H that
doesn't appear to be
that offensive at all
compared to the rest of
the words in the language.
Now, when we compare
language taboos
across the world's
languages, what we discover
is that the types of words
that feed into this list
are actually quite
representative of the world's
languages.
Across the globe, there
are four categories
of words that seem to be
most reliable in providing
the taboo vocabulary
of a language.
That is words relating to
religious concepts, words
relating to sex and sexual
activities, words relating
to other bodily
functions, the organs that
are responsible for
those functions,
the actions involved
in those functions,
the upkeep of those bodily
functions, and so on.
And then finally, slurs.
And those are kind of
the big four categories
that contribute
profane vocabulary.
And if you were to categorize
the list of most offensive
words in English by which
of these four categories
they most properly
belong to-- of course,
there's a little
bit of wiggle room
here-- you would find that
in English, it is indeed
the slurs that, on average
and in specific cases,
are judged to be the most
profane words of the language,
the most offensive
words of the language.
Copulation is also
a near second best.
And religion doesn't really
provide much profane vocabulary
to contemporary
American English at all.
Across the world,
different languages
will sample differently
from each of these columns.
So if you look at Italian,
for example, the strongest
words in Italian
known as bestemmie,
are basically the
formula is this.
You take the word pig, and you
add it to a religious term.
And that gives you a really,
really offensive term.
So [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
or [SPEAKING ITALIAN],
really, really offensive.
Sorry, Italians.
In Quebecois French,
spoken north of the border,
the worst words are
these words called
sacres, which are
Catholic liturgical terms
like [SPEAKING FRENCH],
or tabernacle,
or [SPEAKING FRENCH],
which is chalice.
And these words are far more
offensive than any of the words
that we have on this list for
speakers of Quebecois French.
So around the world, languages
will sample differently
from these groups to find their
most offensive terminology.
Russian has recently experienced
a big regulatory change.
Putin's government
has outlawed a set
of words known as mat, which
are pretty much all drawn
from sexual vocabulary.
And those can now no
longer be used in the arts
or media in general.
So there are differences
across the world's languages.
Now, you may be looking
at these words and saying,
well, OK, this is where
the words come from.
But there's a lot.
That can't be sufficient, right?
There's lots of
words that relate
to copulation or to bodily
functions that are not obscene,
right?
Words that you
would describe when
talking with a child
in kindergarten,
or when talking to your
doctor, for example.
Or when labeling these columns.
Copulation, for example,
is not a profane word.
So there must be something
else about the words that
makes them offensive to people.
And the first thing that
people oftentimes come up with
is the length of the word.
Something about how the word
sounds or how it's spelled.
We have this idea in English
that there's something special
about four-letter words, right?
And in fact, if you
look empirically
at the distribution
of four-letter words
among profane words
compared to what
you'd expect on the basis of
the distribution in the language
in general, you
do find that there
are far more profane
four-letter words than you
would expect by chance.
And that's true even if you
normalize for the frequency
of profane words.
But you find something
else, as well.
It's not just four-letter
words that are more frequent.
It's also three-letter
words, and five-letter words,
and eight- letter words.
And all those differences
turn out to be significant.
So what's special about
three-, four-, five-,
and eight-letter words?
Well, it has something
to do-- if you go back
and look at these
words, you can actually
start to see the pattern.
The eight-letter
words are made up
of two four-ish letter words.
And the four- and five-
and three-letter words
oftentimes sounds
pretty similar.
They may be spelled
with five letters,
but that doesn't mean that
they have five distinct sounds.
In fact, this is an artifact
of English orthography
being terrible.
So English spelling doesn't
look at all like how it sounds.
It's unlike rational
languages-- like Spanish,
for example, or Indonesiann--
that actually do have a one
character per sound dictate.
Well, in English, not so much.
And so in fact, what's going
on with these three- and four-
and five-letter words is
that English profane words
tend to follow a
particular sound pattern.
And that sound pattern is this.
English syllables
come in two varieties.
There are the ones that
have consonants at the end,
and the ones that have
no consonants at the end.
And that makes a big
difference for lots of stuff
that linguists care about.
The thing that you should
care about with respect
to this distinction is
that English profane words
are far more likely to end with
consonants at the end-- they
fall into this
category over here--
than they are to have no
spoken consonants at the end.
And you could come up with
maybe five words in English
that are arguably profane
that show up on these lists
across languages that
people find to be offensive.
And they're really mostly
not that bad, right?
So poo is not the strongest
word in the English language.
Nor is pee, screw.
Jew shows up on some lists.
I think it's the use
of Jew as a verb.
So to Jew someone, or
to Jew someone down
that is judged to be offensive.
So there's not a lot of
profane vocabulary in English
that ends with no consonants.
Almost all of it
ends with consonants.
And this differs from the
language in general, which
is far more evenly balanced
when you look at nouns or verbs
or frequent words,
infrequent words in general.
This is a very
strange distribution
for the sounds of words.
And so you look at
this distribution.
And this might start to explain
part of why certain words are
judged to be more offensive than
others, even though they might
come from the same
meaning source.
But is this just a
pattern in the lexicon?
Is this just a
distributional fact?
Or is this something
that's actually
active in the minds
of English speakers?
Is this something
that you bring to bear
when you're exposed to a word?
Do you have this
pattern in mind?
Does this template
apply to a new word
that you're exposed to?
Well, in order to ask this
question, what we did was
we invented some new words.
We invented words that didn't
actually exist in English,
but that were equally
likely to exist
in English, that had sequences
of sounds or sequences
of letters that are coherent
with how English works,
but just don't happen to exist.
So we made up words like
"ver" and "verd" and "stee"
and "steet."
And we asked people to
make various judgments
about these words.
How much does it
sound like a word?
And also, by the
way, how likely do
you think this word
is to be profane?
And this is what they said.
So we had some words that
started with just one consonant
at the beginning.
Those are these.
And then, some that started
with s plus a consonant,
because that's a nice way
to build more consonants
into the beginnings of words.
And so you see two statistically
significant effects here,
two main effects.
The first is that if
you have two consonants
at the beginning, you're going
to be judged more profane.
That is, higher bars
than if you have only one
consonant at the beginning.
These two bars are higher
than these two bars.
And then, the second effect
is that the dark bars
are higher than the gray bars.
And that's showing that if you
have a consonant at the end,
you're judged to be more profane
than if you have no consonant,
spoken consonant, at the end.
And that's true.
Those two effects are
independent of one another.
So it appears to
be that people have
this template in their
minds, this expectation
that profane words are going
to sound a particular way.
And when exposed to a brand-new
word, they bring that to bear.
Now, this is not
particularly surprising
if you've ever watched
people invent new words.
So consider the case of fiction.
So when you have a fictitious
language, say Klingon
or Dothraki, and
you have to come up
with what is the profane
inventory going to be like,
without exception,
English speakers
make up words that follow this
heavy consonant at the end
pattern.
Moreover, when people
invent new profane words--
and this is happening
all the time--
those words overwhelmingly
follow this same pattern.
So I have the privilege of
teaching at UC San Diego, where
I'm able to consult
on a near daily basis
with undergraduate students
who are aged 18 to 22.
And they know all kinds
of things about language
and how it's changing
that I do not know.
And they bring in new words.
One of the things that I
ask them is to surprise me,
tell me something that I don't
know about how people are using
language in your community.
And what you find
is that there is
a whole host of new profane
words with every new crop
of students.
So you might not have heard
the word "sperg" before.
This is a term of
abuse for people
with Asperger's syndrome.
You might have heard
the word "tard" before.
This is an abbreviation
for retard.
This is judged by
young adults to be
one of the most offensive words
in the language, more offensive
than the F word.
The word MILF, the word
GILF, which is a new one
that I hadn't heard before.
So there's a variety of new
words, which, not surprisingly,
if people have this
pattern in their minds,
follow this heavy consonant
at the end syllable pattern.
Now, why do English profanities
tend to sound like this?
Well, there are a couple
of possible explanations.
It could be that at some
point in the previous history
of the language,
it just happened
to be the case that a
bunch of profane words
sounded like that.
And then, over the course
of history, people-- as they
invented new words--
tended to invent
words that sounded like
the ones that they already
knew that were profane.
They sort of snowballed.
You had this
accretion by the rich
getting richer sort of process.
That's certainly possible.
But it's also
possible that there's
some reason to the rhyme,
if you will, that-- that's
a linguist joke, by the way--
that there's a specific reason
why this particular pattern.
Now, when children start
to acquire a language,
the early sounds that
they're able to produce
are in conformity
with certain patterns.
One thing that's very
hard for them to do
is to produce a bunch of
consonants, especially
at the end of a syllable.
Childlike language
tends to reduce
syllables to just a
consonant and a vowel,
and often repeats if anything.
So it's possible
that these words
are tailored to be
the type of thing that
sounds least childlike.
Not because then children
can't produce it, but just
for the mouthfeel
of the word, it
feels unlike the type
of thing that a child
would be likely to say.
And it also sounds
unlikely to be something
that a child would say.
A final possibility is that
it might have something
to do with the use that
you put these words to.
And I first started
thinking about this
when I saw interviews with
people with Tourette syndrome.
Now, you may or may not
be familiar with Tourette
syndrome.
It's an inhibitory
control disorder where--
it's a developmental disorder.
People have trouble
controlling tics,
which are movements usually of
the head and neck, sometimes
the upper torso.
About 10% of the time, they
also have a particular symptom
known as coprolalia, which is
the uncontrollable production
of taboo words.
And it so happens that
when you ask people
how they control
this coprolalia,
they often report
that what they do
is they can't control the
beginning of the word.
So one person I saw
interviewed, for example,
said that his tic
was the word "cock."
So he couldn't
not say that word.
He would be at work.
He would be in public.
He'd be at a ball
game with his kids,
and he just couldn't
not say that word.
But he could change
the end of the word.
He could just close his mouth.
So "cop," and so
his solution was
to say "cop," cop,
cop, cop, cop.
And he described the effect
as being that people thought
that he was a
little bit strange,
but certainly it didn't
have the consequence of him
not being able to go
out in public anymore.
And so it occurs to me
that one of the things
that having a bunch of
consonants at the end does
is it stops the word.
So if what you want
to do with profanity
is to express a strong
emotion and then
be able to quickly curtail the
audibleness of that expression,
then maybe it would
be useful to have
something at the end that's
not a vowel, but a consonant.
And there's a little bit
of corroborating evidence
for this.
The consonants that you can
stick at the end of a word
are not all equal in their
ability to stop sound.
There are some called
stop consonants,
like puh, and tuh, and
kuh, that really do just
stop the sound coming
out of your mouth.
And if those are
the ones that are
most likely to occur at
the ends of profane words,
then this is consistent
with that explanation.
And in fact, if you count all
English monosyllabic words,
and you look at the
ending consonants,
there are about as many stop
consonants, like puh, tuh, kuh,
as there are nonstop consonants.
That's in the
language in general.
But if you look just at profane
English monosyllabic words,
there are far more stops
than nonstop consonants.
So that's a thing.
Anyway, as you look
across languages,
you find that this sound pattern
doesn't necessarily hold up.
So there are
languages, for example,
that just don't allow consonants
at the ends of syllables.
So Japanese mostly
doesn't allow consonants
at the ends of syllables
except for "n," but no others.
Hawaiian mostly
doesn't like consonants
at the ends of syllables.
So in those languages,
you just couldn't have it.
If you turn-- well, I'm in San
Diego, so if you turn south,
you find that Spanish
doesn't really
have this pattern, either.
Most words in Spanish
that are nouns or verbs,
adjectives, adverbs are
multi-syllable words.
So you don't really get
one-syllable profanity
in Spanish.
So there are
certainly differences
across the world's languages.
So more to be explored here.
But you certainly see that
across the world's languages,
there is a tendency to have
something like profanity drawn
from one of these
four categories,
having certain sound
patterns, although maybe not
these specific sound patterns.
And there are few exceptions to
the fact of having profanity.
But there are exceptions.
So in some languages, or in
some cultures, I should say,
there's not even a setting.
There's not even a
pervasive cultural belief
that there's a set
of words that we all
agree are the bad words that
we shouldn't say in public,
we shouldn't say around kids,
we shouldn't allow kids to say,
that need to be bleeped, that
people should be punished for.
So for example, it's
long been reported
that this is the case in Japan.
So there isn't this
sort of social setting
that there is a set of words
that we need to make sure
that kids are protected from.
So there are lots of ways to
insult people in Japanese.
There are lots of ways to
offend people in Japanese.
You can insult
people's ancestors
and liken them to animals.
That is a really
offensive thing to do.
You can call people ignorant.
You can use the wrong honorific
forms, those little endings
on the ends of
verbs and nouns that
make it seem like you're
talking to someone of low status
rather than high status.
But specific words that
are bad words, not so much.
If you want to say that
someone's-- if you want
to insult someone, you
might use the word baka.
To talk about genitalia,
you might use chinchin.
Some people say that kuso,
which literally means excrement,
is the closest thing that there
is to profanity in Japanese.
But you see it in
Hello Kitty videos.
I mean, it clearly
doesn't rise to the level
of even "shit," which as we
saw, doesn't break the top 30.
So across the world's
languages, the idea of profanity
is actually built off of
something a little bit more
than just having words
belonging to certain domains
of experience.
And more than just having
words that sound powerful,
there's something else.
There's a cultural setting.
And what we find when we look
within a culture across time
is that you get the
exact same effect.
That over the course
of the history
of a language, a particular word
may enter into being profane.
And then decades or centuries
later may no longer be profane.
So it just so happens that if
you know someone named Dick,
he's probably 65
years old or older.
And the reason I know
that is that I went and I
dug into the Social Security
Administration naming
database, which has
records of every live birth
recorded in the United States.
And as it turned out, there
was a long period of US history
in which children were being
given the given name Dick.
Not Richard-- these
weren't Richards
who were nicknamed Dick.
They were actually named Dick.
It said "Dick" on their
birth certificate.
So what I did was I
just counted over,
on a year by year basis,
how many Dicks there were
and how many Ricks there were.
And here's the data.
It sort of speaks for itself.
There was a time when
there were lots of Dicks.
And then, by 1965, there
were no more Dicks.
There were Ricks and there were
Richards, but no more Dicks.
And I actually have
a relative named
Richard who was born
right around here
who went by Dick
until the mid-1990s.
And then, we got an
email saying, by the way,
I'm now going by Rick.
And this is a totally
rational thing to do.
For obvious reasons.
This is a word that had
accumulated enough impact
in its secondary meaning, its
new, acquired meaning, which
interestingly seems to
have arisen indirectly
from a meaning relating
to-- so "dick" first
came to mean a riding crop, like
the handle of a riding crop.
You can see how it then would
be metaphorically extended
to a body part that was
maybe shaped similarly.
But that change took
decades to take effect,
to the point where
people started
to decide that other meaning
is just too invasive.
It's just too problematic
when I introduce myself.
And we see this
not just with Dick,
but you can plot
the same history
with a closely
related word, "cock,"
which used to only
refer to the rooster
before the word
"rooster" existed.
It then gained a
secondary meaning.
It gained a meaning
relating to, well, actually
the same thing that "dick" did.
And at that point, after
some centuries of discomfort,
Puritanical Americans
in the 18th century
decided this was not a
stable state of affairs.
And they really needed another
way to describe, to call,
the male of the chicken.
And they invented a
word based on the place
that that animal sleeps.
It sleeps in a roost,
so it is a rooster.
And that word gained familiarity
and use in the United States,
although it hasn't caught on
in other places in the world.
So you still have, for
example, Great Britain
where "rooster" is sort
of a funny American word
that they know about.
Kind of like how like
a lorry is for us.
It's like, ha, whatever,
you guys are ridiculous.
It was kind of the same thing.
So what we see across words when
we look at profane vocabulary
is that they follow
this pattern.
That at first, they're
not profane at all.
Refer to animals or to people.
That they gain profane meanings.
That those profane meanings
squeeze out the old meanings,
create an externality of having
to invent new words to cover
the semantic ground that
is now no longer covered
by the word that's not being
used in its original way.
And then, eventually,
these words die out.
So many of the most
profane words from English
are no longer used.
So if I were to tell you
that in Shakespeare's time
the equivalent of the
F word was "swive,"
you would only know that if you
were a Shakespearean scholar.
It comes from an old
root meaning something
like to turn or screw.
We have other words
that have followed
a similar semantic pattern.
But it has completely
fallen out of use.
So has "tarnation," and so
has "gadzooks," and "zounds."
These are all words
that, at some point,
were extremely vulgar.
"Gadzooks" comes
from "God's eyes,"
and it falls into this
religious terminology,
but no longer is used at all.
And so this is the general
pattern that we observe.
If we are to project
forward, we can reasonably
assume that the very set
of words that are now
judged to be the most offensive
ones in the English language,
within a century
certainly, will no longer
have the impact that they have.
And it would be surprising
if the F word, for example,
were still censored on broadcast
television in 20 years.
But at the point at which
there is some ambiguity,
there's ample opportunity
for double entendre.
And so just because this
is a real thing that
actually happened, I
wanted to show this.
So right around
here in the 1960s,
there was a very famous
person whose name was Richard.
And his proponents played
on this double meaning
to create this actual,
real political messaging.
It's the type of thing
that you could get away
with in 1955 or 1965
because there was still--
because his name
was Dick, right?
Maybe not the thing that you
could get away with in 2016.
Or maybe actually you could.
I guess we'll find out
in about three weeks.
OK, so what makes profanity?
Well, there's a whole bunch
that goes into making profanity.
First, you have to
have a cultural belief
that some words are bad.
And you don't have to have that.
You could be Japanese and not
have that cultural belief.
Second, you have to apply that
belief to specific words, which
are most likely to be drawn from
certain categories of meaning.
And they make a pattern
together in sound.
And then, in order
for that belief system
to be inserted into
people's brains,
there has to be some
system for reinforcing it.
So there has to be some system
of punishment, censorship.
Ironically, the
punishment-- the soap
in the mouth, the bleeping
on television-- that
is exactly what makes
those specific words
have the taboos that they have.
It is the thing that
recreates that belief
system for each new generation
of speakers of the language.
Now, I wanted to talk to you
not just about what profanity is
and some of the science
of what we know about it,
but also what it uniquely
reveals about our brains.
And so that's what I
wanted to turn to next.
There are certain
facts about how
profanity is used that differ
from the rest of language.
Profanity is emotional.
It evokes emotions
in other people.
It is inhibited.
It is the type of
thing that you know
you're not supposed to say
in certain circumstances.
And as a consequence, it
uses different brain systems
from the rest of language.
And I'm going to show you
now two kinds of things
that we learn about how
our brains compute language
on the basis of
this side effect.
So the first has to
do with speech errors.
Speech is peppered with errors.
I've tried to not
produce many now.
But in fact, people produce
roughly an error every thousand
words.
It's a lot.
In particular, it's been
believed for a long time
that the speech errors
may reflect thoughts
that people have that
they are not consciously--
or that they are consciously
trying to suppress.
And if this is
true, then we might
expect to find that
repressed thoughts produce
more taboo errors than non-taboo
errors, all things being equal.
And certainly, we tend to
notice when people make
speech errors that are vulgar.
So here are two examples.
This is-- if you watch the
news enough, live news,
you'll get this.
Examples like this-- I hope
that the audio works here.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Up next, we're
going to share when
your partner may be in the
mood for a little romance.
-And we've been in the
food fuck-- food truck
business all week long.
Food, truck.
-What did you say?
-Food truck business.
That's what I meant to say.
Gulp.
High five!
Lunch truck is here with us.
-Yeah, high five
yourself for that.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BENJAMIN BERGEN: OK,
food truck business.
OK, here's another example.
You could find--
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-It's a sausage
competition that I judge.
-Oh, like sausage eating?
-Yeah.
-Oh, neat!
-Cape [INAUDIBLE] Kielbasa
and local sausage makers, they
all make their best.
And they enter it.
-I bet it's delicious.
-It is.
It's February 9, 7:00
PM at Prairie Land Park.
Tickets are only $25.
It's for charity.
And you can get tickets online
at pickadick-- pick-- oh!
-Well, you're thinking
about sausage, so.
See that?
She said, well, we're
thinking about sausage.
[INAUDIBLE]
-My goodness.
That was ridiculous, wasn't it?
-We were not
drinking wine today.
-No, we weren't.
We weren't.
-That was some
really good advices.
-It is. [INAUDIBLE] Kielbasa.
So go to pickadick--
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BENJAMIN BERGEN: OK,
so these are the ones--
feel sorry for her, right?
She probably enjoyed the wine.
But these are the errors
that we notice, of course.
Because if she said pick a
kick, no one would care, right?
Wouldn't make a difference.
It doesn't violate a social
expectation about behavior,
for example, on
broadcast television.
But when you actually
look, when you
do the controlled experiment,
I won't give you the details.
But when you create
conditions for people
to produce errors that are
either taboo errors like those
or neutral errors that don't
produce any taboo language
at all, what you find-- there
have been a variety of studies
up.
Showing you the first two.
The data hold up and have
held up for nearly 40 years.
You find that people
are far more likely,
they make many times
more-- depending
on the study-- they make many
times more neutral errors
than taboo errors.
And that's actually revealing.
Because why would you be
able to avoid making errors
when the error would be taboo?
Well, the interpretation,
and the thing
that we've learned about
language and the brain
from looking at this, these
taboo errors specifically,
is that in the cases when
there would be the most
damage to make an error because
it would be a taboo word coming
out, those are the
conditions under which you
avoid making errors.
Which implicates an internal
self-monitoring system.
And there's a whole
bunch of research
that's grown up around this
idea that perhaps when you're
planning to produce speech, when
you're activating those words
in some grammatical organization
and you're going to speak them,
that you do a
little sanity check.
You run an internal
simulation, an internal model
of what it's going to be
like to say those words.
And in the case where
there is something bad
coming down the pike,
you pull the lever
and stop the assembly line.
And we actually know
now, by comparing
cases where people are induced
to make errors that would
be profane, like "hit shed."
OK, if you switch the
first sounds of "hit shed,"
it would be taboo.
If you switch the first sounds
of "hit said," it would not be.
So if you compare what
happens in a person's brain
when they successfully
avoid making
an error on the taboo ones
versus the neutral ones,
you find that this is
the part of the brain,
right here, that's
doing more work,
avoiding making a taboo error.
It's a particular part
of the brain known
as the right inferior
frontal gyrus that's
part of the system specifically
responsible for, wait for it,
inhibitory control.
It's responsible for-- you know
when you're sitting at a light,
and it turns green,
and you're about to go.
And then, all of a sudden, the
light changes-- maybe there's
a fire truck coming from
the other direction,
and it did that
magical blinking thing
where it changes the lights?
So your ability to
not do something,
to inhibit the execution
of that action, that's
what the right inferior
frontal gyrus is implicated in.
It does it in
general, when you're
moving around in the world.
And it does it specifically
when you're avoiding
producing profane language.
And we can see this in
people's behavior, as well.
So people are
suppressing, they're
trying to inhibit producing
profane words in tasks
like this.
So this is a task known as
picture word interference.
If you give people a picture
and say, name that picture, what
is this a picture of,
as quickly as possible,
and measure how
long it takes them
to say what the
name of that thing
is, and then print an
irrelevant word over it,
you find that as long as the
word doesn't have similarity
in sound or meaning, it doesn't
interfere with naming the word
or saying the word "dog."
But what happens
when you give them
a word that they're
supposed to ignore that they
have more trouble ignoring?
Well, you find that saying the
word "dog" in this circumstance
takes people
significantly longer.
The taboo distractor
slows people down
to say the word "dog."
And the reason for
that is because they
are activating this
inhibitory control mechanism.
Their brain is saying don't say
that word, don't say that word.
And it slows down the
production of any word.
The second major
finding that I wanted
to talk about with
respect to the brain
has to do with the originators
in the brain, those circuits
that are responsible
for producing language.
Now, if you've taken an
introductory psychology class,
or linguistics
maybe even, you will
have learned that in
almost all people,
there are language
centers housed
in the left hemisphere of the
brain specifically responsible
for particular
language functions.
Broca's area articulates words,
or lines them up, or something.
Wernicke's area is
responsible for word meaning.
Primary auditory cortex
is responsible for hearing
the sounds that then are
interpreted in terms of words.
And there's a lot of
truth to all of this.
The thing is that when
people have damage
to these different
parts of the brain,
they have damage to
the specific functions
that those parts of the brain
are supposed to be involved
with-- with some exceptions.
And we've known
this for 150 years.
One of the first
scientists to study
the incapacitation of
language due to brain damage,
known as aphasia, was a
researcher and physician
known as Jacques Lordat.
He was arguably the founder
of neurolinguistics.
He was born in 1773.
He was trained in Montpelier.
And at the age of 52, he
suffered a debilitating stroke.
And that stroke left him
basically unable to speak.
But he recovered.
And he began to study people
who had similar conditions, who
had had some sort of brain
damage leading to an inability
to produce language.
And his most famous case
was a parish priest,
a man of the cloth who had
a stroke, lost his ability
to speak entirely,
had no ability
to speak with the
exception of two words.
And those two words were
the French word "je,"
which means "I" or "me," and
the second was, as Lordat wrote,
"the most forceful
oath of the tongue,
which begins with an 'f,' and
which our dictionaries have
never dared to print."
The French F word starts
with the same letter
as the English F word,
as if by coincidence.
And so this is now common
knowledge among aphasiologists,
that people who have
damage to Broca's area
will lose language in general,
but not necessarily swearing.
Many people who lose the
ability to produce language
in general-- and this is due
to traumatic brain injury,
due to stroke, like
in these cases,
Alzheimer's disease
can cause aphasias,
as well-- a variety
of different causes
can lead to this same syndrome.
So patients, for
example, will be
looking at a picture
of a dog and a cat.
And they're supposed to say
the dog is chasing the cat.
And they can't say the
dog is chasing the cat.
So they'll swear.
The most extreme
example is from people
who, for medical
reasons, had to have
their entire left
hemisphere removed.
So the most convincing case
is a patient known as EC.
He was 47 years old,
right-handed man, left
lateralized for language.
And he had severe symptoms from
a substantial left hemisphere
tumor on his frontal lobe.
So over Broca's area.
The tumor was removed but was
determined to be malignant.
And so his doctors decided to
remove the entire hemisphere,
a radical left hemispherectomy.
And so what happened?
What happened in the
case of his language?
Well, this is what happened
according to his doctor,
after his entire left hemisphere
was removed at the age of 47.
"His attempts to
reply to questions
immediately after operation
were totally unsuccessful.
He would open his mouth
and utter isolated words,
and after apparently
struggling to organize words
for meaningful speech,
recognized his inability
and would utter expletives or
short emotional phrases like
'god damn it.' Expletives and
curses were well articulated
and clearly understandable."
Doesn't have
language except when
he's swearing due
to frustration, due
to strong emotional states.
Now, what could possibly be
the part of the brain that
can support language, support
emotional communication
if the entire left
hemisphere is removed?
Well, we know because
of specific case studies
like this one.
So this is the case of a
particular individual who
is a bilingual French Hebrew
speaker, 75 years old,
right-handed.
He had a stroke.
And after his stroke,
he was unable to swear.
All of his language was
preserved, except for swearing
and a couple of other things.
He could not provide
the correct expletive
for situations described to him,
nor could he complete a curse.
Now, if you know people who
speak French or people who
speak Hebrew, this is an
absolutely strange state
of affairs not to
be able to curse.
And so here's the payoff.
Where did this
particular subject,
this particular
patient, where did he
have brain damage
from his stroke?
He had damage in the right
hemisphere of his brain
in a place called
the basal ganglia.
And basal ganglia are a
part of the limbic system,
which is responsible
for emotion regulation.
The basal ganglia
in particular seem
to be responsible for deciding
what actions to perform
and what actions to not
specifically perform
on the basis of an
emotional state.
So I'm angry, should
I fight or flight?
I'm angry, should
I say something?
If so, what should I say?
That sort of thing.
Or should I not say
anything at all.
That appears to be what
the basal ganglia do.
And so it appears that we
have a second system that
can produce vocalizations.
And there's some
corroborating evidence again
from Tourette's syndrome,
which I mentioned earlier.
When people have
coprolalia, it can
be through Tourette syndrome,
but other sorts of diseases
produce it, as well.
When you have
coprolalia, these are
the types of words that you
are unable to suppress saying.
They look a lot like the first
list that we saw, in fact.
And what brain mechanisms are
impaired in Tourette syndrome?
That's right--
the basal ganglia.
Basal ganglia are
different in people
who have developmental
Tourette syndrome than people
who are neurotypical.
So what we learned from this
is that there are actually
multiple vocalization
pathways in humans.
There's one pathway,
the one over here on you
your left that's in
blue, that doesn't really
involve all these smart
evolutionarily new cortical
systems that we think are
the things that evolved
that allow us to do language.
Instead, this system
is a sort of a shortcut
that we share with
other mammals.
And in fact, even
other vertebrates.
It's a system for vocalizing
that other primates,
for example, use when
they're expressing fear
or identifying a predator
that's in their environment.
On the other side in
red, you have the system
that is our new system.
So we have two
capacities for language.
One for reflexive automatic
emotional language,
and another for rational
cerebral intentional
communication of ideas.
And again, we wouldn't know
about this binary system
of pathways, these
two pathways, if it
weren't for profane language.
So profanity works differently
from the rest of language.
It sounds different.
It changes
differently over time.
It's processed
differently in the brain.
There are significant
gains to be
made in the science of language
by looking at profanity.
But first, we have to overcome
the stigmas associated
with these most powerful
words of our language.
I'd like to thank you now,
and then welcome any questions
that you have.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was curious, what
is the most long or complicated
profane word?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: The longest or
most complicated profane word
is surely one in German.
But so German speakers,
help me out here.
So in English, I don't know.
So there is a lot of
productive use of profanity.
There are a lot of
these parts of words
that you can add on to other
parts to make bigger ones.
I couldn't hazard a guess.
But I would guess it would be
in a language like German that
creates words out of
lots of little bits.
And so it probably has
something to do with--
AUDIENCE: But they're
all sort of compounded.
BENJAMIN BERGEN: That's right,
they would be compound words.
Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
Is there any difference
between taboo words
versus like explicative
curse words?
So in the former sense,
where it's more thought out,
methodical to insult somebody's
ancestor or something
like that, and
the latter being I
want to just get my emotion out?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: So you can
ask people about their feelings
about words, and you can
get some dissociations
between the following
two questions.
How offensive is this
word to you personally?
How offensive is it?
Versus, how taboo do you
think it is in the culture?
And there are some
words that differ.
And you find interesting
differences in, for example,
across genders.
There are certain words
that, for example, women
will find very
offensive, but not
judge to be that
taboo, and vice versa,
that men don't seem to have
the same sensitivity to.
So those two things do
certainly dissociate.
And in fact, if you
look at the words that
are produced during
coprolalia, they're
actually more properly
described as taboo than profane.
And the reason that I say that
is when you look at coprolalia
in Japan, where they just don't
have that set of profane words,
the words that come out are
often words describing-- they
can be childlike words
for bodily functions
or for sex organs,
or words describing
visual characteristics of a
person, like fat, or dark,
or whatever it is that they're
not supposed to be saying
about how another person looks.
Those are taboo acts of
talking, even if the word itself
isn't offensive.
So yeah, the two do
kind of disassociate.
AUDIENCE: When you say we
have this secondary mechanism
in language, has a
different pathway,
how does that then work with
the Japanese, for example?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
there's almost no words there.
And then, my second
question is, what
would be the difference then of
you saying "go fuck yourself,"
versus like, "go
copulate yourself?"
BENJAMIN BERGEN:
Ah, what would be
the difference in terms of the
brain mechanism underlying it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah, OK.
So we don't know what happens in
the brains of Japanese speakers
when they do whatever is
most closely equivalent.
We do know that if you
take people, run them
through an fMRI machine and have
them either swear or produce
minced oaths-- so
not fuck, but frick.
Not shit, but shoot--
you don't get anything
like the same sort of
limbic system activation.
So in English speakers,
those alternates don't count.
We don't know what happens
with Japanese speakers
when they use
words that are kind
of equivalent to the
minced oaths that
are kind of like, aw, darn.
It's possible that something--
it could go either way.
Empirical question.
But we know that the
physiology is different.
So when you expose people
to strong profane words,
it triggers this fight
or flight response,
this sympathetic
nervous system response
where adrenaline starts pumping,
heart rate increases, blood
flows to the extremities,
pupils dilate,
you get narrowed vision,
and you're ready to react.
That doesn't work
for Japanese speakers
with the pseudo-profanities
that you could use things,
things like kuso and so on.
So there's good reason to
believe that their brains
probably don't do that thing.
Now, their brains would
do that for other sorts
of emotional vocalizations.
So I imagine that when sumo
wrestlers do their yelling
at each other thing,
there's probably--
and if it's emotional for them--
they're probably activating
that vocalization circuit.
It's not language, but it's
kind of that same thing.
AUDIENCE: I guess
what I'm asking
is, if they would drop
a brick on their toe,
right, you'd say a word here.
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah,
it's an empirical question.
Like I said, we just don't know.
If they were just to
vocalize something--
AUDIENCE: Isn't there a
reaction, even nonverbal?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah, yeah,
verbal stuff comes out.
It's just not profanity per se.
So it's either nonlinguistic,
like the equivalent
of "ow," or it's stuff that
is the equivalent of "darn."
And so yeah, what
we don't know is
what's happening in the
brain in the latter case.
You had another question?
It was--
AUDIENCE: The difference
between "go fuck yourself"
and "go copulate yourself."
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Oh, yeah.
Well, for sure, a
huge difference.
So the second has to be
computed compositionally
through that left hemisphere's
system of cortical operations.
"Go fuck yourself" could
actually happen either way.
You could be
deliberately calculating,
how am I most going
to needle this person?
Like, what is the word
that is most likely to get
this person riled up?
To get under this person's skin?
I'm going to say,
"go fuck yourself."
You could calculate that
entirely rationally,
cortically.
Or it could be produced
via hot cognition.
So that actually has
two ways to produce it,
which is the really
interesting thing.
It's not that profanity is
just generated one place
and the rest of language is
generated somewhere else.
It's that for a particular
biological purpose,
you have one way to generate
the exact same words that you
can generate through a
different assembly line.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
really interesting
to hear about the side of the
speaker, like why people cuss
or why they swear.
Like, it seems like
it's like a release
almost in terms of trying
to get those emotions out,
like you said.
But I'm wondering,
have you done studies
on the other side, the recipient
side of people in the room
with you if you swear?
Like just this
morning in a meeting,
someone said this swear
word, and everyone broke out
laughing.
And I find that to be
a common occurrence.
And I wonder, why
does that happen?
Do people swear to get
that kind of reaction?
And I think of musical
artists as well,
like rappers and
hip hop artists.
But yeah, just want to
get your take on that.
BENJAMIN BERGEN:
Yes, great question.
There has been a lot of
descriptive work trying
to characterize why it is that
people respond differently
in different contexts
to the same words.
So why does a set of words,
when produced by a comedian,
you've decided to go
watch that comedian.
You know that he works--
or she-- works blue.
You know that it's Allie Wong.
You know that it's going
to be really vulgar.
You're prepared for it.
She could say a set
of things that, when
produced by, say, a
political candidate,
would have a totally different
physiological response in you.
A large part of it has to
do with our expectations
going in, and particularly of
the social dynamics at play.
So people use profanity to
cement social relations,
to demonstrate that this
is an informal situation.
They use it to be
funny, to break the ice.
They use it to display power.
So if I'm the boss,
then I can show
that I'm the boss because
I can use casual language.
I can use profanity.
Whereas the person
who is not the boss
might not get away with
that same type of language,
and might be judged
to be-- that person
might be thought to be
misjudging the situation
if they think that
they can get away
with using the same language.
So there's a lot of
social work that people
do-- not social work, but
do with profanity.
And we are constantly
calculating
what we can get
away with and what
the consequences of
our linguistic actions
are going to be.
You know, if you've worked
in a place for a long time
with a particular set of
people, what the rules are.
Who's going to be
offended by what?
And so those are
oftentimes the places
that people feel most
comfortable using profanity
to do a variety of things,
like seem funny, break the ice,
like cement social relations.
In new situations,
now I'm first day
on the job, that's
probably not going
to be your go-to because you
haven't taken the temperature
of the environment yet, right?
So there's a lot of evidence
that in workplaces, people
use profanity for lots
of different functions.
And that, in general,
people who use profanity
are judged to be more
accessible, more informal,
and more powerful.
But depending on
the power structure,
it could be that they're
judged to be brutish,
or they could be judged to be
out of touch, or inconsiderate,
or out of control.
So again, it's all about--
I'm not a sociologist,
but it's really about the
social dynamics at play.
AUDIENCE: What do you feel
about the common process
of trying to steer children
towards less profane words?
You know, "shoot" instead of--
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah, well,
I mean, it totally works
every time, right?
Because if I don't
swear, then they're
just not going to learn it.
Right, yeah.
So this is something that
I have thought a lot about.
Have a two-year-old at home.
And so this is a
conscious decision
that you have to make
as an adult around kids.
You have to decide how
you want to expose them
to all of these complexities
that we've just been talking
about, about the social world.
And it's certainly
the case that there
are certain types
of language that
can cause harm to children.
Verbal abuse, calling
children worthless,
insulting them,
threatening them.
That's all stuff that
is known to cause harm.
Slurs are known to
cause harm in kids,
so kids in middle school who
are called by homophobic slurs
report-- in
correlational studies,
because you can't do
this experimentally,
obviously-- but they
report increases
in depression, anxiety,
detachment from school.
There's lots of stuff
that's not good to have
around kids linguistically.
But there's no evidence that
just the fleeting expletive
because you tripped over a
kiddie gate in the middle
of the night is the
type of thing that
will cause harm to a child.
What will cause
harm to a child is
if they don't know
that using these words
in certain
circumstances is going
to have consequences for them.
And so there are lots of
ways that you can teach them
what the consequences
are going to be.
My preferred method is to
explain what the consequences
are going to be.
Kids do a lot of
social learning.
When you potty train-- I
have a lot of familiarity
with this-- when you potty
train a two-year-old,
for example, most
of the learning
is about there are
certain places and times
for particular activities, and
lots of other places and times
that those activities
are inappropriate.
Like on the couch, or in
the middle of preschool.
And that's a thing that
a two-year-old can learn.
And a two-year-old can learn
that this is a language
that I use at home.
And I use this other language,
because I'm bilingual,
at school.
Kids can learn that.
And so I don't see any
reason that kids can't also
learn that this is a word that
Daddy uses when he's upset.
It's not a bad word, and
Daddy's not bad for using it.
He's not a bad person.
But if you use this
word at school,
expect that some people
might not like it,
and there might be consequences.
OK, go ahead and explore.
Do what you're going to do.
That's my general view of
what the literature tells us
best practices ought to be.
AUDIENCE: I'm coming at this
from a linguist's direction,
as I'm sure you know.
I'm interested in sort of--
it seems like there's even
from the neural level,
there's kind of two things
you could be probing.
There's the things that have
this inhibitory response, which
I think is really
your core category.
Those are the
forbidden words, right?
And you have a constant monitor
to try to prevent yourself
from producing those.
And when you do
produce them, you
have to inhibit the
inhibition, so to speak.
But then, there's
this other category
of sort of limbically
produced words, right?
Are those really
exactly the same?
Or do words like "ouch" get
used in like left brain removed
people?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yeah, they do.
AUDIENCE: That's what
I was going to say.
There's an exclamative category.
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Yep,
those exclamatives
will often be preserved.
So interjections
are often preserved,
things like "oh, no," or,
"um, I mean," or "ouch."
Yeah, those will
oftentimes be preserved
in Broca's or global aphasia.
Not always.
But they often are.
And they seem to be exactly
what you're describing.
It's, I'm in an emotional state.
I'm producing language, uh--
this is going to come out.
So it seems to be generated by
a different system, for sure.
AUDIENCE: So as you became
immersed in this work,
did you find your personal
production rate of expletives
to increase?
And if so, what did
you do to fix that?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: As Nancy
says, it was impossible
that it could increase.
Increased, in a
way, because now I'm
talking about all these
words all the time.
So it increased in
professional contexts.
No, if anything, I
think it decreases
because-- there's this effect.
As you get exposed
to these words
over and over and over
and over and over,
they start to lose their
impact a little bit.
This is kind of what's
happening with young people
and the democratization
of media.
So 20 years ago,
when you only ever
got exposed to
language and media that
was filtered
through some censor,
you didn't hear
these words much.
Now, the media is
in your pocket,
and directly from someone's
thumbs to your eyes,
you get a stream of language.
And if you're playing
video games, network games
before breakfast,
you'll get 100 F words
before you go to school.
So kids are exposed
to a lot more of this.
And as a consequence, I think
that's part of the reason that
you get this consequence, which
is that those run-of-the-mill
profane words start to
creep down the list.
The F word isn't judged
to be that bad anymore
by digital natives.
So the same has happened to me.
In a way, these words just don't
really do much for me anymore.
Sorry, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for the bad-ass talk.
So it appears that
repeated exposure decreases
the impact of profanities.
So I have one or two questions.
Depending on your answer
to the first question,
I might have a second one.
So the first question is, would
English-speaking societies
be better off or worse
off if profanities
just lost their impact, or
disappeared from the language
somehow?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: They
would be different off.
I mean, it would be a
little bit more like France.
So in France, there
are profane words.
There are bad words.
But they're not as
bad as they are here.
So you don't see them censored
or bleeped on daily television.
You could see them on the
evening news broadcast.
You could see them around kids.
You could see them
produced by kids.
Even the strongest
words, even that F word
that our dictionaries have
not seen fit to print-- I
saw the president
of the republic
say it on the floor
of the senate.
So you might end up with
something like that.
Where yeah, you
can use the words,
they just have a little
bit less social cachet.
And so they do a little
bit less emotional work.
That's what you would
end up with, I think.
AUDIENCE: OK, so at least we
will unemploy a few censors
and perhaps have them find
more productive lives.
So the second question
is as you know,
Google has made some attempts
at de-radicalizing Muslim
terrorists by showing
certain [INAUDIBLE]
search results when they
search for radical materials.
So it's a form of
mind influence.
If you were at Google and
had some control over this,
what would you do to reduce
the impact of profanities?
BENJAMIN BERGEN: Well,
you're leading me
down the path of saying, well,
we should just show more of it,
right?
But I think that
what you need to do
is show it in specifically low
emotional arousal contexts.
So the reason that we
think these words are bad
is because early in life, we saw
them used or heard them be used
in strongly emotional contexts.
Someone was really frustrated.
Someone was experiencing
strong pain or was really angry
or was really excited.
We used them, and we
got a really strong
emotional reaction.
That emotional
substance is what makes
us think that they
are powerful words,
and that we have
internalized, we've
associated because
we're Hebbian learners.
And now, we can't help but have
that emotional response when
we're presented with that word.
However, the decontextualized
presentation--
you see a list of words and
study them over and over
and over, that has no
reinforcing emotional content.
And so I guess you would
have to, if you really
wanted to de-escalate the
emotional value of those words,
they would need to be presented
in unemotional contexts.
So I wouldn't show,
I wouldn't show,
those words used in strident
political discourse,
for example, or in other sorts
of highly emotional context.
I would show them
in lists of words
or in analysis
context, or some sort
of really boring, mundane,
anodyne place, I guess.
But you know, I'm
not an engineer.
So that probably wouldn't work.
I don't know.
Thank you so much!
It was a real pleasure
to talk to you.
[APPLAUSE]